every year polluted air in India's
capital city between November and
January contributes to the deaths of
thousands of people including children
although air pollution in New Delhi has
long been a problem how the haze
develops has been poorly understood
you'll have a very clear like nights in
Delhi sometime but then there are other
nights where
yes
things will develop very fast maybe
starting with 5 PM by midnight you will
start seeing that appearance of haze and
then by vrs in the morning you will find
that there is really a thick Haze
scientists know how pollutants become
more dangerous in sunlight when gases
react and lead to smog as has been
documented in Beijing
but it wasn't clear what was happening
at night in New Delhi so Chemists in the
city deployed 1400 sensors on rooftops
to monitor the air
what they found surprised them as the
temperature dropped and humidity Rose
minute particles grew fast forming ultra
fine ones ten thousandths of the width
of a human hair
they were mostly made up of organic
molecules
so the scientists realized they must
have come from vapor from burned
materials like wood
the molecules turn to Vapor then
condensed like seeds in the cool air
then grew in the presence of water
that connection had not been known
before whatever is getting burnt or you
know being combusted in and around Delhi
it's simply contributing to this Haze
formation
the process peaked after midnight before
tapering off as commuters headed to work
before 9am when the haze was thickest
now that the transformation is
understood it could help city planners
and public health and Aviation officials
but some say they face substantial
challenges
we don't have infrastructure to
provide heating to
the low income population of the city we
don't have infrastructure to provide
cane cooking as of now and we're
building it as long as these problems
are not solved biomass burning is not
going away it's stated that may also
prove useful to a world that is seeing
more wildfires near more population
centers every year Colin Baker Al
Jazeera